[Applause]
hello everybody the last Jedi has
happened it's happened it is in the
universe so crazy Wow
I'm gonna preface this video with the
very obvious we are going to be talking
about plot points and spoilers spoiler
warning I'm gonna put it all over this
video it's all over the place so if you
haven't seen the last Jedi please please
close that tab it goes against my job to
like yes what are you doing yeah yeah
you clicked on this video you clicked on
this video it says spoiler on it so
that's all the warnings there you go yes
so we're gonna be deep diving into
everything about the last Jedi and here
to join me my guest and best friend
Jermaine Lasserre Ashe thank you for
having me thank you I'm excited it's
been a long wait for this movie and we
saw it last week two weeks ago I don't
remember a time yeah at the premiere and
now but now we could finally talk about
it because we had like for a bunch of
days where we couldn't say anything to
the world no now we could say it's with
the whole world so we both saw at the
premiere we kind of went up to each
other at the after party and we were
just kind of like huh it just is so much
it's I didn't know what to say my mind I
felt like I had eaten a full meal which
is something I do often and it was just
I was too much it was so much happens in
this movie yeah I'm excited to just
let's list
piece by piece this night there's my
life before and after the last that's
the thing about these movies right so
we're such fans that it's like when you
see a new one it's like your life does
change because the story up until this
point was ended with Luke Skywalker on
that cliff yes now it ends with Luke
Skywalker's dead like now everything's
changed it's changed now everything life
has changed because as a Star Wars fan
now the whole story has this new chapter
let's start with the ray and Luke
dynamic because that's where we picked
up sort of at least in the story right
cuz it was pretty funny to me like I
think I expected to Luke to be a little
I mean he was dark but he was just kind
of like ah no no it's sort of is that's
the moment where the mutant of you're
expecting a baby yeah he takes that
light saber you been waiting two years
to see what he does
does lightsaber that was his was his
father so it's been lost for 40 years
and he throws it over any felder you
know what is this movie yeah and you
just but you expected him to be like Oh
ray you're strong with the force let
do that like let me train you and make
you a Jedi but he has no interest in
that and then she is like follow him
around like he's this weird hermit
killing animals like he's like cliff
crimes it's so weird like milks for
nipples so bad and then of course the
pores are there yeah but I like but I'd
like to die because it's so different
because eventually he realizes that she
is somebody special and so he does
begrudgingly try to teach her but in her
own way his own way is he says I'm gonna
teach you three lessons I'm gonna teach
you why the Jedi have to go away like
whoa okay and and that's just so
different he's not like you know like
Yoda trained him you know or obi-wan
trade and Anakin you know like it's a
totally different thing with like this
end game and it's crazy surprise wow
this is all happening we keep going back
to to Leia and Poe and hold oh yes and
all these guys you know getting beat up
basically nowhere to go they run out of
fuel but I thought it was like I I
wanted to see more Poe from force
awakens and then we see this Poe that is
just like thinks he knows everything
he's so cocky and he just knows nothing
but doesn't see we don't know that at
the beginning we don't like we not like
he doesn't trust hold oh but I mean
that's one of the my problems with the
movie small problems is I mean hold it
obviously is a strong leader I really
like the character why didn't you just
tell him like hey I have this plan don't
worry
yeah it gives her the opportunity to say
like you know like do we have a plan and
she's like oh no not really but she has
a great plan the plan is to get to crate
where she doesn't tell she could have
just told him and solved so many things
I mean that makes them there's not a
movie then yeah just like a power play
to of just being like you're not yeah
that's true you don't have a ranking
that like I don't need to tell you
anything you need to trust me yeah I'm
in charge you sit down yeah lay demoted
you right before she died slash came
back to life and again and that's oh
that's another one of those weird
moments where the movie you're like this
is not gonna be the moon no we're all
right I thought she was dead I was
because Carrie Fisher obviously passed
away right and so and we had Brian
Johnson and said she survives through
the movie but then she's out there and
she gets the star-lord face from
guardians of the game that's like
exactly yes
and you're like oh my gosh she's dead
and I was like getting all cry and then
you get like this like moment we should
like floppies force flies through space
I don't know I I don't know how to feel
about it I don't know how people like I
don't know how everyone feels about it
yet really but I liked it and like hated
it at the same time because I was like I
I'm so excited to see Leia use the force
on screen like for real for the first
time besides like sensing Luke yeah yeah
it was just like I started crying but
then I was like this is but that's this
movie it's everything about it is weird
everything we expect to happen in the
Star Wars movie Luke's just gonna train
right Leigh is going to die in space
because none of it happens you know and
then stuff later we're going to talk
about with smoke and Carlo and Ray none
of what you expect that happen happens
and and I love that about it let's go to
Finn Andros so here's the thing I always
thought that Poe was like the hon but
now sometimes I think it's Finn because
Finn's the one that's like reluctantly
keeps trying to leave they're like guy
you're taking your prize ago and he's
like yeah that's exactly what I'm doing
I'm really trying to leave yeah and
everyone just pulls him back in one by
one they're just like no you can't leave
you can't leave yeah cuz he loves he
loves the ladies
he does like the ladies which is I guess
as a reveal cuz everybody wants him to
be with Poe yeah we still are not sure
about Poe
what if he loves the ladies of the boys
or anybody or the four nippled weird
things on act 2 we could like at all
yeah I like the Roses and Finn dynamic
because again it's different you know
she's like a fan of his like you said
he's like reluctant he gets pushed on
this mission only because he has these
information but I think well I love both
boyega and Murray Tran in it in their
chemistry that storyline is so pointless
I I agree with you I could have totally
done without Canterbury and I was really
close I love it I love the planet yeah
yeah I loved everything about it like I
was I read like half of the Kanto bike
book before seeing the movie and I was
like I'm really interested in like it's
essentially Vegas um but then and
there's like a shot in there that's
really beautiful like when they first
like come into canto by but it was like
what are we doing here yeah and well
it's basically you know
narrative Lee it doesn't end up playing
off because DJ who's bonito there's
character you know flips on them and
they don't need to code anyway because
all those gonna kill herself but and
then but it it is crucial for two
reasons one it gives you this really
interesting thematic thing about like
warmongering yeah and like how you
profit in the Star Wars universe which
is never something we've really seen
we've never seen rich people on the Star
Wars University besides like you know I
guess we have like I'm Nabu here and
there yeah but this is like these are
like yeah these are the fat cats yeah
and the fact that they sell to the first
order and the resistance really makes it
gives you this like complex little thing
nugget to chew on right in the middle of
the movie which I like and also that's
where the kids are that come back at the
end yes so you need you need to
introduce them you need to juice broom
kid you know broom kid which is the last
shot of the movie I did kind of like
because in force awakens I fell like
everything was going so right like it's
just like here's our plan there's got to
be a hole right it's like a desert yes
there is
I know let's blow it up you can blow it
up right yeah we can blow up everything
just goes swimmingly perfect and I kind
of the only thing I kind of liked about
the candle bite thing was just like it
didn't work out at all that's true
that's a great point because so yeah if
you take it and just circum
compartmentalize it like that it's
apropos of the movie where it's like
everything is not what you expect this
is not gonna go the way the fact the
fact that it doesn't amount to anything
is kind of perfect in the whole thing of
the movie so that's a great point I
didn't even think about that I didn't
want to go back that's what I remember
the Leia thing right the very first
thing right
the in that scene you know she gets back
but then later they're like Oh
everybody else in the bridge died like
Akbar died and you're like yes Akbar has
been this major character throughout the
entire Wald's thinks Jedi kilims I'm
ceremoniously and just mention it yes
honey I didn't even know I didn't even
hear it or like remember it until
afterwards somebody mentions oh yeah
that bar dies I mean what haven't you I
was just like what yeah cuz you expect
him to have like a little bit of a death
you know yeah I don't know yeah I mean
it's okay I mean there's also like Greg
Grunberg hair covered our first movie
snap Wexley doesn't come back and you're
like oh well is he dead
and he's actually reportin cuz he's the
main character or like the third main
character in the aftermath series okay
so you're like oh man well what happened
to him and then I guess and this is real
Star Wars nerd stuff I guess in the
visual dictionary as somebody who was
showing me there's a little thing that
says many of the star fighters who with
Poe on Starkiller base were off on
separate missions during this time okay
so so even though they tell us in the
movie that that's the whole rest of the
resistance like fourteen times there's
only 400 of us there's only 100 of us
other people were out in different
places so don't worry Greg Grunberg can
come back Wow it's hard to say wow Greg
Grunberg running home grunt granny's
coming back running be back ronnie is
coming back hold Oh like Lightspeed
kamikaze yeah that was a holdup Kyung's
that was amazing because not only is it
an intense great character moment it
happened simultaneously with phasmid I
oh my god cool action scene in this
movie I forgot she was in the movie
until she showed up right okay just
brought it up and I was like oh my god
yeah that's right phasma yeah it's I
mean I named my dog fast yeah your dog
has been around for infinitely more time
the fact that moment of tension where
holder's doing this they're turning it
away I can't remember so many things are
happening in that moment right that it's
so exciting it's such a perfect moment
for her and it stinks that week that
she's gone because she was a very strong
leader and like you made some good
points earlier about her
just putting PO at arm's distance yeah
she was yeah it's a it's such a cool
moment and it's very again I don't think
we've seen really that in Star Wars I
mean we've seen like a wing fighters run
into starter stories and stuff you know
they're gonna go down and they you know
use their last moment but for her to so
consciously do that was it's a great
sci-fi moment and we've seen it before
but never but never with the Lightspeed
whatever that you take down this huge
thing Snoke ships so cool okay yeah
again that's just like a thing that I
hadn't thought of just like you can just
write speed through things yeah if you
can Lightspeed out with the money Falcon
in the last movie why can't we do this
you know like let's this
use this incredible power in a new way
and that's the whole movie you know it's
like we have this ship can go the speed
of light let's not just use that to like
go fast let's use as a weapon that's so
different and cool and you know like I
said it's just disappointing that that
means old is gone but her death also is
sort of it makes the resistance that
more desperate at the end right we have
to just get to this because it's like in
the back of my head this whole time is
when Ray gets to smoke yeah / Kyle oh
yeah and they're like they've been like
forced connecting them this whole time I
know what are you a low Skype session I
love it about this movie but I think
it's the hardest for me to wrap my head
around it is just like this aspect of
the force that I just had no idea
existed there's a bunch of that and
there's so much of that I think that's
why I'm so excited for Rian Johnson to
do a whole new trilogy yes he just gets
it more than more than I can even wrap
my head because everyone else is sort of
played it safe and I love the force
awakens but that movie is very safe like
you said everything sort of works out
everything's kind of what you expected
to be and he's like we live in a
universe where there's talking slugs
laser swords and hyperspace
can I you know make them talk via the
force yeah can I have Luke hologram
project himself onto another planet yeah
look why not the force can do anything
yeah right if you have the power of it
like a Jedi you can do anything so
that's Rian Johnson's really like it's
like he took out everybody else is going
like 65 going the speed limit
yeah he is pedal to the metal up until
this point I'm like the force is like
essentially like Matilda you know you
can yeah it's a touchscreen it's not
just moving rocks yeah yeah so they have
their Skype sessions and snoke's
connecting them and they get in there
and I have I don't know if I've ever
been that mind blown you know in a Star
Wars movie yeah I mean I guess you can
argue like the Empire Father moment but
for me I had already known that that was
like a pop culture for now by the time I
saw Empire so that was just such a crazy
moment because it was so good we're
talking about Snoke being killed yes yes
yeah because he's the main bad guy and
we waited two years to
see him in the flesh and to find out who
he is where'd he come from
and then like the third scene he's in
kylo Ren kills him and then it just goes
into this like insane slow-mo
back-to-back samurai shot oh my god I
lost it I was so excited it was it was
again so awesome and exciting and and
also so surprising because like you said
he that's like they killed the Emperor
in the second movie it's like you know
it's crazy anything it was just
literally anything you thought was gonna
happen they were just like nope and even
if you could predict how how they what
would happen you could never predict how
they would get right like he said he's
gonna kill him with Anakin saber and
then they have this huge samurai fight
and we're cool and I'm gonna put a saber
look through someone's head never done
that before and like you do all these
things oh and then Carlo is gonna like
shame ray into like saying she knows who
her parents are and they're no one so
all the theories that all these fans had
for you two years but who Snoke is and
who raised parents are he's dead and
there no one no one get the hell out
that was the only thing that I felt like
mildly fanservice you because they kept
saying like show me my parents are maybe
your parents are let's talk about yours
the whole moment I feel like it really
feels like Ryan really understood the
fan reaction to the first movie because
even like the poor's right like the
porks are cute in the movie but then
there's the scene where Chewie almost
eats a poor bright and I feel like they
had to be and I'm sure it was in the
script cuz we're I mean like I said he
understood it but it easily could have
been like just put in later when he saw
the fans loved the poor's he wanted more
cute pork shots and he wanted that
tension of will somebody eat pork
because that didn't really become a
thing until like you know you started
like hashtag poor nation like it became
a thing and it's in the movie how is it
in the movie he just understands it I
just I need to interview him and ask him
when exactly that was put in because at
this moment in time I am convinced it's
late edition right
I hope convinced too that was just like
these people are all talking about
cooking Borges and and you get these
shots of of the cute pork shots you get
these like adorable pork shots and
you're like oh
somebody's gonna like gift that me doing
the port noise yeah it's it's perfect
like that like you said with the with
the smoke stuff with the race stuff you
finally get to see Luke like showdown
with the first order which is again
these are all things we'd kind of
expected the first one didn't get and he
just like wipes the slate clean to me
this movie could have been either 7 or 9
because the great palate cleanser to
start the story but also was kind of a
nice closure to the story right so
everybody the the resistance is in
shambles the first order is kind of in
shambles they're so powerful but they
got this new leader he's a madman you
know like you could have you could have
ended it there with the hope of a little
kid and the resistance coming back you
know or you could have started it there
it's almost like I was like oh man I
wish there was two more movies in this
trilogy because now I I don't like the
force awakens less but maybe I do I'm
not really sure I I'm not really sure
either and I totally 5 scene it like you
know 15 times I've seen this one twice I
need more time yeah figure it out yeah
it fit me I think it took me a solid
like four times the force awakens before
I was finally like able to decide how I
truly felt of the greater good even
still I'm still trying to figure it out
I want to talk about the Luke thing too
because yeah that was very mind-blowing
because he shows up on crate right yeah
and they're like someone's here a
haircut he looks a little younger yeah
yeah why does he have why does he have
the saber that was destroyed like three
scenes are we going that was the that
was the moment where I was like
something's up but I couldn't exactly
figure out what it was and what was in
my hand I thought he was dead
and I thought it was like some kind of
force ghost or something cuz he like lit
up the blue saber and I was like did
Ryan just totally mess that up
you see what iconic yeah that's the
moment where instructed me that
something was wrong but at the same time
I just was like maybe he made a new one
maybe that wasn't the saber yeah I was
like we'll find out if we don't find out
it's a big thing you know I was thinking
about steel during that moment too cuz
he's been like ignite the Green ignite
the green you see who have take it out
yeah and it's the only time we get to
see him with the saber and it's not
Reed's not even really there it's kind
of yeah it's kind of let down but it's
kind of interesting for Luke's journey
because Luke is not that guy anymore
he presents himself as that guy to help
the resistance help his sister yeah and
then and that's it and then he's like I
have served my purpose here I have put
the people that need to be together
together peace out
you know and he's got to come back as a
force ghost Mark Hamill is still on his
diet you know what I mean right
Kathleen Kennedy was saying you know
Episode nine would have been Carrie
Fisher's movie and I feel like now that
there's really not any legends to be in
that movie I feel like they'll
definitely bring Luke into it yeah
either way either way yeah if they
weren't going to they're definitely
going to know yeah yeah I mean that's
probably I mean yeah I mean with Carrie
Fisher passing and then Luke dying at
the end it's movie you can understand
why episode nine has had all these
struggles this movie it's way more wide
open than the other ones like I think
episode 9 will probably start 10 or 15
years later like like a like a much
bigger time jump because if you start
right there there's way too much to do
but if you start it with like Ray has
been like learning more about the forest
passing on a little bit of what she's
learned resistance it's kind of back
broom kid is now can be casted like a 20
year old actor and a famous actor and
you started Leia's funeral she does she
she passed away and now everyone's there
and then like the story starts that like
to me that's the that's the way to do it
yeah you know I
that was kind of immediately what I
thought of because it is such an open
ending with you know and and with Leia
still alive right Luke gone it's tough I
mean I don't envy Judy Abraham's having
to tell the rest of the story because
Rian Johnson just crushed it shook it up
oh my god like a coke can that's like
been shaken up it's like you can open it
would you rather see Moran Johnson do
episode 9 or are you excited for it to
be JJ the Cadi filled up after this I
wish Ryan had continued his story but I
think he'll because he's doing his new
trilogy he'll be around the office ya
know I'm sure he'll visit said he'll
have input and JJ's an amazing filmmaker
there's like no if ands or buts about it
you know he understands nostalgia he
understands epic action and all these
things he's going to make a great movie
it's just not gonna be a Rian Johnson
movie but thankfully we do get more
babies at some point yeah I mean like
after seeing a I kinda wish Ryan
adenylyl trilogy because as great as
force awakens is as nostalgic and
hitting those notes is I wanted the last
Jedi is what I wanted episode seven to
be where I walked in being like I'm
seeing a Star Wars movie and I walked
out and I said no now I'm seeing a
different kind of Star Wars movie right
this was the first one even counting
rogue one that's a different Star Wars
movie I totally agree it's like Kathleen
Kennedy was saying you know in the at-at
the junket and stuff she was like oh I
knew immediately that I wanted Rian
Johnson to do his own thing and do his
own trilogy and you can totally see why
because his imagination is just wild
yeah but yeah I mean JJ was involved in
eight so it's not like he doesn't know
what's going on and he's just walking in
and being like executive producer he's
there I mean but he had no creative
employee paycheck you know so it'll be
it'll be interesting I think he's gonna
do a great job and then Ryan can go off
and change what a Star Wars movie mate
means you know and that's really
exciting and people are gonna say like
oh these trilogy is gonna star the
little kid at the end of the movie it's
a no I don't think so I think it's going
to be like everything this movie is so
unexpected and I think that's going to
be whatever you expect completely
different because that's the kind of
movie you may yeah and people keep being
like do you think it's gonna be you know
like their to the or republic or they
keep you know pulling these things out
of legends i'm i don't think it's gonna
be any of that no needs to be something
like and they've kind of said this it's
gonna be something we never even heard
of even think of yeah it's gonna be
awesome to sort of follow it as as he
sort of they drop little hints or titles
or cast yeah we sort of start to make a
movie in our mind like we did with this
one and then when we sit down for it and
it's not final thing I want to talk
about is is the ending of Luke because I
thought it was so perfect to start his
journey and and his journey with a
binary sunset yes oh my god beautiful
it's so beautiful and for him to help
everybody in that way and such a badass
way to like those teams with him in
Kyllo and Luke standing and you see like
all these you know the new walkers like
I was like I this is what I imagined
would happen after Return of the Jedi
Luke
Skywalker being the most powerful Jedi
in the galaxy would be able to destroy
an entire army by himself and you're in
like he sets up for that he doesn't but
again spins it and yeah like I'm so
curious if we're gonna learn more about
how he's sort of how he sort of goes but
it was beautiful
it was very beautiful and very perfect
in that moment in the way array andele I
sort of process it was very very nice
and again even after two viewings as
something though that I'm still sort of
struggling with that looks there's no
more there's no more look it was like to
me it was just like he was using so much
of the force that it it was like his
last yeah I mean yeah we just I'm still
trying to figure out did he Jedi mind
trick him more today actually was he
actually I guess he was actually or he
like touched people right yeah he handed
off the the Hans device it was just like
some but it's like an astral projection
it's one of those things like you said
that it's something that we'd never seen
the force do right yeah he's awesome
okay well yeah that's like our surface
level reaction yeah it's gonna be one of
those ones we're gonna be talking about
it for days weeks months years
we could've dates we could have done in
videos on each one of those points oh
yeah I'm sure we're going to yeah and
I'm sure in related to this so far
plenty of people who have yeah like such
a dense mentally such a great movie yeah
there's so much to dissect yeah and yeah
Brian you killed it man you killed it
Ryan
awesome kill a lot of people to Akbar
justice for Akbar
yeah well thank you so much for coming
in we'll keep talking about this on text
phone more videos exactly I'm I'm ready
to go All Star Wars all day well let
everyone know where they can find your
your work yeah I write for io9 and
Gizmodo you could find my stuff there I
know on Twitter and Savannah everything
and a Tremaine was here it's my best
friend drive man
thanks guys see you next time